hey man you're looking fresh i did i
changed did you uh are you doing a
little dance to celebrate this movie
like you did for your 43rd birthday no
no
there's a little gran cormino involved
on my 43rd birthday this is
a sober setting uh me in this
environment amazing energy amazing
families around so excited
in round five for you and dj together is
it can we officially now say that you
guys are hollywood bffs that he is your
favorite co-star you know what i gotta
be honest man it it is like he uh we
have a great relationship on screen off
screen and you know things like this
don't just happen right it's uh it's
something that you definitely have to
you have to realize like how special it
is because it doesn't have to be this
way you don't
you typically don't have the
relationships on screen and off at this
magnitude so i love the fact that we get
along i love that we respond to the
material that's been presented to us i
love them still finding new ways to be
creative
you're on your reality check tour you
brought up will smith's slap in your
stand up act have you talked to will
about the incident uh yeah i mean look
will will is apologetic um you know he's
in a better space of course than what he
was after people are human and as humans
sometimes
we make mistakes so
it's not about talking about the past
it's about acknowledging the present and
doing your best to move forward so i can
only hope that the two of them find a
way to uh find some solace in that and
move past it
i just like good energy i love to see
people be the best i still love him i
still love chris and uh you know you
can't judge a person by one thing
ultimately you know life goes on and
people grow so give an opportunity to do
so